on
va les battre
[Musique]
salah
juriste
c'est ce que c'est l'europe
oui
l'europe par exemple il on fait une
homonyme du pays comment avec quels sous
peu
non cachetée péquiste paix en fera
grâce à l'europe on n'a qu'une seule
monnaie
magic wand à l'europe à 27 pays c'est
beaucoup 27 pays
je te dis j'y vois quelque chose
d'extraordinaire ou de magie que tu y as
muret pour les 27 pays
quand
[Musique]
je souhaite que cette conférence sonne
l'heure du recours des grands projets
des grandes ambitions des grands rêves
quelle robe voulons nous dans dix ans
dans 15 ans en france nous organiserons
des débats citoyens dans chaque région
ce sera un exercice inédit quand la
synthèse des contributions et des débats
sera établi et j'en prends l'engagement
au nom de la présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne nous
responsables politiques des différents
états membres du parlement européen de
la commission devront en tenir compte
pour réformer l'europe
[Musique]
bonjour madame alors je vous appelle ont
été mandatés par le mr de l'europe nous
a pas trop cher pour vous contacter par
rapport à la grande conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe qui va se dérouler
en septembre prochain
je vous appelle à propos des conférences
de l'avenir en europe afin de les
inviter à y participer
c'est une chance à saisir ou nativement
acceptez vous de participer à cette
conférence citoyenne menace l'europe si
tout le monde dit toute façon rien ne
changera bien sûr que rien ne changera
d'accord y'a pas de soucis en tout cas
merci beaucoup madame de votre accueil
et je sais qu une excellente soirée
[Musique]
j'étais au téléphone je sortais du
travail on m'appelle moi je n'ai jamais
entendu parler de cette conférence c'est
quoi au juste pas possible c'est une
arnaque c'est facile sur ses parents
donc la conférence cités sous l'europe
de votre région se déroulera du 10 août
ou septembre prochain merci beaucoup au
revoir monsieur
[Musique]
je suis chahrazed j'ai 34 ans j'habite à
marseille et je suis responsable d'un
magasin
partant les gens je pars ce week end à
la conférence de doha ouais c'est ça qui
était sélectionnée avec d'autres
personnes mais je l'étais pas je sais
pas qui c'est je vais rencontrer bien
n'a pas de marseille mais je sais pas
c'est sa mort apparemment ils ont dit
qu'ils allaient avoir un échantillon que
j'ai posé la question
représentatif de la région paca on peut
les y aller franchement grave j'ai trop
contente
[Musique]
bonne journée commence par un beau petit
déjà
je m'appelle laurent je suis chauffeur
routier depuis 35 ans j'ai 58 ans
j'habite dans les hautes-alpes dans un
petit village qui s'appelle obraniak
l'europe le principe était bien le
l'union fait la force le principe est
très bon mais l'europe qu'on nous
propose c'est une europe de bain de
technocrates qui c'est à dire ils votent
des lois que qui est qui les concernent
pas
nous ici
ça nous va très bien notre mode de vie
y'a pas de bruit y a pas de pollution
on entend le coq ça les néoruraux il
aime pas trop mais bon je changerai pas
pour tout l'or du monde
ça allait trop vite ça a été lors des
six lors des 12es s'allier faire une
europe des douze forte là les filets
derniers pays qui sont rentrés ça a été
de devant il accrocher les wagons en
catastrophe et eux ils sont juste là
pour tirer la sève mais il faut pas
rêver le jour où la chine viendra leur
dire que leur proposer quelque chose de
mu marrant et puis c'est tout
et puis nous on restera payer les pots
cassés donc voilà il fallait pas qu'ils
fassent une europe aussi cros à saray
nouveau logo faut être comme moi
sensuellement robin
j'aime bien partir tu préfère attendre
une demi-heure qu'être en retard de deux
minutes et la ponctualité c'est très
important
on a négocié avec éclat
plus car mon
[Musique]
grand père et je vais à marseille et
dans la région sud est je travaille à la
climatisation je suis chargé d'affaires
dans le département du nord
le color n'a pas trop parlé d'europe par
l'europe comme un continent au mondial à
l'afrique l'amérique ou autres données
que l'europe pour moi être une puissance
pour ça vous pourrez faire des choses
avec l'europe et où je n'aime pas cette
question j'ai jusqu'à maintenant et
c'est sympa d'en parler donner un peu la
parole aux citoyens s'expriment et
surtout
[Musique]
le transport routier jusqu'à une
vingtaine d'années jusqu'à ce qu'ils
aient les pays de l'est ce qui arrive
dans un marché de l'europe c'était bien
parce qu'il y avait une régulation des
tarifs donc ça a évité de le dumping
justement depuis qu'elles les pays de
l'est sont arrivés ils ont pris tout le
travail à l'international nous on n'a ni
ennui resterait à faire que du national
donc c'est petit à petit en train de
bouffer
or maintenant il faut trouver parking
salle mozart
[Musique]
on est partis au secteur et on arrivait
à 11 ans
et 5 ans patron georges on a le temps
[Musique]
bonjour
sont les contacts mais merci à vous
d'avoir des échanges
[Musique]
jours que nous avons fait la conférence
régionale
à 15 heures
à cette fois qu
est-ce que vous avez des questions par
rapport au processus de participation
citoyenne quelques questions la première
sur la finalité de ces discussions
comment seront exploitées nous invite
donc en restera-t-il au final est ce
qu'on sera écouté la première écoute je
me suis dit tiens encore une usine à gaz
mais je suis là bon week-end l'une de
nos questions ci comment avons nous été
choisi est-ce que ici les gens ont fait
la démarche de venir
même on ne se sentant pas européen
oui je vais jamais une personne de 3,4
plein de personnes il fait
l'organisateur pour faire une espèce de
plante d'image du ressenti des gens ils
demandent de se mettre au cul d'une
estrade un petit moment de détente les
plus européens et les européens
convaincus d'un côté et voilà et ça va
s'cauet européen et le moins convaincu
ou voir comme j'étais tout seul l'enfant
lanceur européen extrémistes ont sages
leur verdict
et voilà je me suis retrouvé tout seul
au fond comme à l'école
pour moi
c'est une tour de babel c'est le thalys
avec des messieurs costard-cravate
attaché-case tous pareils pas beaucoup
d'âme c'est clair
je me sens vraiment pas européen et je
veux pas et je veux pas l'être
peut-être là qu'on change leurs
familles
partie de la famille des associations
est mauvaise et amy guerre
on a le souvenir le plus mûri de
l'europe c'est le passage à l'euro mais
ça m'a enlevé du cours de chant depuis
un grand
pas pour tous pour tous je veux dire
c'était 5 francs café s'est passé à une
roue s'affaisser francs 50 et
regarde dans une boulangerie rentrer
dans une boulangerie
avant alors où je rentrais 1 et comme il
fallait prêter
ci valent même pas la c2 aussi car ça
fait quoi de nouvelles bases je te quand
il s'était remis en francs il
fonctionnerait pas un gâteau ans a même
balle il se vend pas un gâteau alors moi
je suis boulanger pâtissier
gbg le passage à l'euro map logique j'ai
converti exactement les prix le franc a
été convertie et êtes malheureux soit
une hausse de 7 ans s'en étaient restées
aux frappes tu crois qu'aujourd'hui
leclercq ici serait amusant ce mal
c'est difficile parce qu'avec
l'inflation avec mai
à 19 ans je mangerai plus que la
gagne 0,58 donc ça nous en soule
ok j'ai un contre exemple
il ya vingt ans une télévision ça va
aller
bibal aujourd'hui avec 250 e valentin
est grande
tu crois que ça n'aurait pas été pareil
c'est nous j'étais pourtant il ya des
tuffes à augmenter et à d'autres tribus
les transports aériens frère edward
pasquale je pars je pense que la télé
cendres ou cinq week-ends baisser les
prix parce qu'il ya un serment plus mais
je pense que sur l'ensemble il ya un
lissage quand même moi c'est la pression
que j'ai aimé c'est vrai qu'ils ont fait
l'histoire de l'électroménager même les
voitures saab je vois d'ici finale du
1000 euros ça fait soixante cinq mille
francs d'amendé s'il est bien mais c est
moi même situation après
le clash est
bon ton avis sur les chocs est
alors un peu mal mais elle s'excuse à
bhl par l'humidité ambiante il dort son
petit peu nous sont bonnes
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde je m'appelle alan
donc je vais de marseille donc les plus
et les moins donc je vais parler des
plus en trouver dans un premier temps
donc ce qui est revenu sur la majorité
du groupe c la monnaie unique et la paix
et par contre même majorité de points
négatifs qu'on a qu'on a pu remonter une
absence de politique étrangère où j'ai
une défense une armure va dire aux
européennes
la législation sociale manque
d'uniformité où nous des droits des lois
entre chaque pays et l'harmonisation
fiscale qui est importante cd des
inégalités entre chaque pays européen
bonjour à tous je suis chahrazed je
viens de marseille dans ce qui
fonctionne la monnaie unique la paix on
a parlé de coopération entre les états
ensuite dans ce qui marche pas
l'absence d'une défense européenne
military diplomatique mais il a très
bien dit
merci pour ça tu es riche
[Musique]
oh
bon ça
on
voit on
[Musique]
ou alors tu me la journée c'est la
question
mme al
maghrib
on n'est pas spécialiste mais
son discours
après du pt mais même si on sait pas en
fait on va écouter ici c'est la mossade
fekki
en fait on n'a pas vraiment sur ce qui a
été impressionnant mais vraiment moi ça
m'a ça m'a marqué c'est de voir ces
personnes engagées est vraiment ils
étaient vraiment engagés parce que c'est
sûr on prend du temps de trois jours
d'un week end on se rend disponible avec
des personnes qu'on ne connaît pas on
sait pas qui c'est qu'on a rencontré et
en fait c'est là où il ya de la richesse
chez les hommes et les femmes en fait on
a la capacité de communiquer peu importe
d'où on vient
[Musique]
l'objectif de la séquence c'est vraiment
de reposer les fondamentaux actuellement
l'europe c'est un gros paquebot mais
comment arriver à le diriger
effectivement arriver à ce fait en sorte
que tout le monde soit entendu ça
rejoint également ce que tu disais sur
une possible présidence de l'europe via
un suffrage universel direct actions et
propositions concrètes ariane avait
parlé d'un salaire
le minimum j'ai pas fait cesser la
partie écologique parce que je sais que
tout le monde est là dedans c'est un
sujet prioritaire manière tout le monde
et tout le monde a raison c'est vrai
mais je voulais plus max et sur un autre
sujet la partie travail
salaire minimum garanti europe 1 ça veut
dire que il ya un salaire minimum dans
n'importe quel pays d'europe mais qui
est le mec qui est le même
vous voyez ce que l'on peut acheter avec
10 euros 5 euros
ici en allemagne et puis les pumas
l'enfance lothian collègues
nous on a eu comme sujet la construction
de l'europe sociale et l'identité
européennes donc on a fait deux groupes
et on en a déduit que une construction
sociale doit passer par une meilleure
réglementation du travail j'ai pas
habitués de parler c'est pas mon métier
et du coup quand je parle je suis vite
pris d'émotion et c'est des petites
jambes qu'il faut favoriser qu'il ne
faut pas oublier et c'est des gens qui
sont très longs en europe voilà bits
dans dans 0,5 ce département rural dont
il a parlé je me suis retrouvé en lui
dans le sens où ils parlent de ce qu'ils
vivent et moi quand je pense je prends
de ce que je vis des problèmes que je
vois et ça m'a beaucoup touché pour ce
qui est du transport routier
il faudrait remettre en place une
tarification obligatoire c'est-à-dire
éviter que le transport ne goûterait
pour diminuer le nombre de camions qui
roulent il ya des camions qui roulent
pratiquement à vide du qui traverse
l'europe où la france parce que le
transport n'est pas cher s'il transporte
était plus cher ça permettrait de 2 et
d'une de diminuer les camions donc
serait bon pour l'écologie de de monter
le prix des salaires des chauffeurs puis
tout le monde serait gagnant la sortie
voilà merci
à la fin il ya un tirage au sort en fait
donc les six personnes qui vont aller à
paris mi octobre pour rencontrer les
autres personnes qui auront participé à
des conférences dans d'autres régions
j'espère que je vais être sélectionné
parce que moi j'ai envie de représenter
la région paca suspense parce que quand
nos bijoux
monsieur perrin alan
[Applaudissements]
madame beyala belle
madame avoir fait la main innocente
[Rires]
je suis dès qu'il soit pas sélectionné
laurent c'est le jeu dessinant passage
son séjour nous rend il faisait partie
de ces personnes qui pouvaient amis
ouvrait une réelle voie en fait à la
prochaine étape
il faut qu'ils rentrent face à une très
grosse communication sur la fonction
dans le rock this aucune sur
l'institution sur l'institution en
europe la bce sait où ces
trois
occasions via les deux communautés dont
quelques uns à avoir un interlocuteur et
poser des questions et met un truc ça il
n'y a pas du tout
la commission est la commission c'est la
commission européenne ou encore dans le
long terme ou non la bourse à strasbourg
[Musique]
c'est partager si vous allez regarder
mais
aux tissus lamés panne à bruxelles et
vous demandent ils vous indiqueront le
gala où
vous allez il ya un gros bâtiment
bonjour nous sommes bien d'accord vient
d'en bas
wattpad
rendez vous avec g14 faire ou jeu
concernant ses 89
enfin bonsoir
bienvenue dans la capitale glacial de
l'europe ma caméra vous adore photo
ma
grand mère vous adorez vous allez prenez
vos vélos et on va me revoir le
parlement à diego
mais louis
regarde une attaque
le froid tout
[Musique]
voilà
ici devant le parlement ça se passe
comment
si c'est censé justement le parlement
européen c'est censé représenter des
peuples d'europe c'est là vous voter aux
élections européennes une fois tous les
cinq ans et vos représentants sont ici
la différence d'autres parlements et il
n'a pas le il peut pas proposer des lois
en france avec le parlement français
peut proposer des lois ici c'est pas
possible les propositions de loi elles
sont faites par la commission qui est de
l'autre côté
qui à peu près 200 mètres d'ici et là
seule la commission européenne peut
proposer une web mais si compliqué quand
même entre l'union européenne la
commission européenne le parlement ça
l'a dit mais c'est compliqué mais si je
vous demandais par exemple de 6,2 me
dire quelles sont les compétences du
conseil départemental par rapport aux
compétences de la région et par rapport
aux compétences de la municipalité par
rapport aux compétences de l'état si je
vous demande de dire la répartition
entre la loi et les règlements en france
1 les articles 34 et 37 de la
constitution
vous aimez vous les connaissez pas ah
non il ça vous empêche pas de vivre donc
le fait que vous compreniez pas les
moindres détails de ce qui se passe ici
au fond on s'en fiche totalement c'est
pas le sujet ces événements on
s'approprie ces onze y a quelque chose
qui se passe ici ja on adopte des lois
européennes qui pourraient avoir dans
certains domaines un effet sur sur la
façon dont on vit e
où
à bruxelles on parle du triangle du
pouvoir la commission européenne ce et
la plus connue en france on parle
énormément la commission européenne la
commission a décidé la commission
sociale et que nous en soyons là est le
vrai pouvoir il est derrière vous dans
cette oeuvre à l'intérieur c'est ce
qu'on appelle le conseil européen des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement vous
avez les 27 chefs d'état de gouvernement
pour nous emmanuel macron qui viennent
là quatre fois par an minimum et les
chefs des gouvernements règles et gros
problème européen à l'unanimité rien ne
se décide contre eux quand un chef
d'état de gouvernement rentre chez lui
en disant je me suis battu comme un
dingue
mais j'ai perdu est-ce que c'est pas
vrai s'est dit moi ça me pose un vrai
problème ce qu'on va décider chez moi
les autres vont dire ok on décide pas
parce qu'il n'est pas question c'est un
club de gentleman battante de quelques
femmes aussi qui sont chefs de
gouvernement et on est entre ceux entre
nous et on va pas m l'inde est l'un des
nôtres en difficulté voilà ça donc c'est
toujours un accord aujourd'hui
sept pays sur les 27 présidents de
chaque pays sont d'accord exactement
alors la loi donc elle est impulsée par
le conseil européen est ensuite allé
moulinet par la commission européenne et
ses fonctionnaires sont trente mille à
peu près parce qu'ils sont pas que là
ils sont énormes bah non en fait ça
paraît beaucoup comme ça mais c'est
moins de fonctionnaires qu'il y en a à
la ville de paris alors c'est vrai que
la ville de paris par les fonctionnaires
on compte aussi les balayeurs les
éboueurs et c'est ce que qu'on compte
pas ici au sein de la commission c'est
une administration de conception mais
c'est rien trente mille fonctionnaires
c'est pour le roi 150 millions
d'européens à servette je ne sais pas
charrier lyon dans le voit quand même
bien sûr qu'on est chez les
fonctionnaires ont un statut de
fonctionnaire il travaille mais
je ne rentrerai pas dans ces
considérations provocatrice
haïti c'est l'humour c'est un peu plus
lumineux la pop à la sécurité a pas
énormément de policiers
sécurité c'est vrai c'est une annonce
assez c'est assez cool donc ici c'est
normalement le gouvernement de l'europe
non jeudi soir quand je rentre dans la
commission je suis fédéraliste ce que
j'y crois à mort
l'union européenne mais quand j'en sors
je suis souverainiste parce que ils sont
insupportables il se comporte comme
étant les gardiens des morceaux de la
vraie croix
je continue à croire au projet européen
vraiment parce que je pense qu'il n'y a
pas de moyen terme c'est où on fait
l'europe où on fait la guerre et
contrairement à ce qu'on croit on peut
très vite très vite se refaire la guerre
franchement c'est quand on a vu par
exemple au moment de la début de la
pandémie quand les allemands et les
français ont décidé de ne plus exporter
leur matériel médical vers l'italie et
que les chinois sont arrivés à la
rescousse en disant vas nous on va vous
donner des on va vous donner des masques
en l'espace de trois mois les pour les
italiens le principal ennemi de l'italie
c'était l'allemagne est le principal
ennemi l'italie c'était la chine
en trois mois ont fait basculer les
peuples dans là elle a une rapidité
inimaginable donc il n'ya pas de moyen
terme j'y crois toujours mais je pense
que si on continue comme ça l'europe ne
survivra pas il faut lui redonner de la
passion de redonner du coeur et surtout
la rapprocher des citoyens et maintenant
sont allés manger une petite frite
relais une fois les vallées chauffe et
rsa
vous
angela merkel emmanuel macron
apparemment en pleine soumis qui vont
manger des frites quand qu'il claque la
frite et comment on fait la chancelière
comme ça voilà damman donc rester comme
ça vous avez commandé voilà oui alors
nous dire bonjour ok ça aussi
ça c'est de la frime belge après
européenne heureusement françois était
trop bas champs d tout en plus il
faisait froid i'm ok heureusement les
européens toujours pas eu l'idée de
faire une directive réglementant
l'aspect coup de chance
[Musique]
saiem est arrivé est là du coup ça c'est
le conseil européen sipa le betting font
ça c'est beau c'est que c'est du bois
oui j'ai entendu dire que vous avez vous
vois dans les 27 états européens pour
faire la façade d'ailleurs tu vas te
regarde la lutte est allé vite
oui tu comptes du vtt pourriez vous
partager
un très beau voyage
bonjour bonjour
chahrazed pineau hockey chanter voilà
bonjour voila voila vous êtes ici le
chef d'état se réunissent d'accord c'est
impressionnant c'est impressionnant
tapis rouge d'accord c'est pour nous
aujourd'hui se pose à d'accord entre les
jeunes on passe sur le top je bouge et
là je me dis mais je suis à un endroit
où emmanuel macron les mamies ancien
président ils sont passés donc trump
c'est impressionnant on se dit on est
vraiment dans le pouvoir free devrait on
va rentrer dans l'une des salles les
plus importantes où les décisions se
prennent
pour des privilégiés quoi priver les oui
oui parce que le monde extérieur est
rarement rentrer ici là c'est magnifique
c'est impressionnant et là on sait quoi
en fait les interprètes à les
interprètes d'accord qui pendant la
règle en parle chaque chef d'état peut
parler d'un salaire nous savons qu'après
ces produits s'est traduit donc des gens
qui meurent des 27 est en fait cette
salle on la voit à la télé c'est pas là
mais c'est à dire que chaque chef d'état
ce soir à kinshasa si vous voulez
essayer on va là où ça la france quand
même
alors je m'assois
un endroit que je vois à la télé en fait
je vois ça à la télé et je me dis je
suis assise sur le siège des manuels
macron donc là je me suis dit peut-être
présidente un jour on sait pas c'est
mythique la
écoutez monsieur mac rend si vous avez
besoin
serait il ya sur l'europe je suis là
on est là on est là on est tous là tous
les citoyens français et tous les
européens aussi seront là pour faire
avancer l'europe bien sûr tu peux
t'asseoir monsieur on a un nouveau
président français où je rêve c'est ça
un jour
chez l'assistante personnelle des
présidents michel c'était mon jour pas
d'angoissé
tout va bien non non
c'est ici
bonjour
de vous rencontrer venez vous venez dans
le nord j'ai exactement marcel c'est
exactement ça vous pouvez retirer le
maximum si on est autorisé à distance
c'est ainsi être sans être son master
moi j'ai une question du coup pendant la
crise du coup il ya l'italien moment
donné elle a eu un manque et ceux qui
lancent qui les ont aidés s'est lâché
donc est ce qu'à ce moment là il n'y a
pas une pas une fracture mais un conflit
du fait de la confiance en termes de
pays européens parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est l'allemagne et la france qui
découlent et y est paisible d'une
européens qui étaient autour qui gré et
de ces personnes après c'est vrai que
ces images la mention très bien de ces
images des avions venus de chine avec
eux avec avec des masques et des
respirateurs c'était univers douloureuse
pour le projet européen ce à ce moment
là donc il ya eu un premier réflexe de
certains leaders politiques ont dit on
va fermer nos exportations va garder le
matériel médical pour nous parce qu'on
va en avoir besoin pour nous et notre
première responsabilité de protéger
notre population très rapidement j'ai vu
la prise de conscience des chefs d'état
et de gouvernement que c'était une
erreur et que l'on devait corriger on
d'expliquer aussi à nos citoyens que
c'est important effectivement d'être
solidaire parce que si un pays européen
est totalement vacciner il en fait pas
protégés parce qu'il y aura constamment
des risques de contamination si dans le
voisinage il y à des taux élevés de
contamination cette question de la
pandémie est là elle a aussi montré des
forces et ça il faut le voir aussi la
capacité de la deûle à des démocraties
européennes de mobiliser des ressources
gigantesques pour réussir en quelques
mois développer des vaccins des
ressources gigantesques pour réussir en
quelques semaines à transmettre
industrie pour produire en europe des
masques des respirateurs et c'est là une
capacité assez rapide en qualité on ne
sait pas que c'est l'union européenne
csah en fait tu le sais tu ce qui baisse
et la france en fait mais c'est la
france aussi
en fait on se dit c'est le président
français qui a mis tout ça en place mais
en fait je n'étais pas tout seul on sait
qu'il n'est pas tout seul qui travaille
avec des personnes et tout ça mais on ne
sait pas qui travaillent que les autres
pays membres il ya un an 27 chefs
d'états de l'union européen on aide
aussi un gigantesque
paquet financier pour la relance
européenne pour garantir une solidarité
européenne s'il n'est pas eu cette
décision européenne certains pays
européens sont plus puissants et bien
évidement que d'autres et donc certains
puis le pays européens qui sont moins
endettés qu'ils sont plus prospères
avait la capacité de pouvoir réinvestir
massivement dans leurs économies donc
soutenir leurs entreprises et donc en
fait créer une concurrence très un
risque de concurrence déloyale à des
entreprises d'autres pays européens plus
fait le plus fragile il a été très
dangereux pour la prospérité en europe
pourquoi parce que nos entreprises
françaises belges allemandes elles sont
interconnectées donc là on peut dire que
toutes les entreprises qui ont été
sauvés en france ou ailleurs c'est grâce
à l'europe et à tous les pays d'europe à
leur bas jouent un rôle clé je suis
totalement convaincu que j'étais une
décision dans cinq ans dans dix ans on
se retournera et on dira mais
heureusement que pendant quatre jours et
quatre nuits ils ont été capables de
négocier plus de décider ensemble je
m'attendais à quelqu'un comme on dit
chez nous en costard-cravate point c'est
un peu un peu coincé et voilà qu'il nous
accordé cinq minutes et être pressé
avoir vite et rendez vous et en fin de
compte il est resté presque une heure à
parler avec nous dans ses conférences
européennes c'est que des citoyens est
ce que vous pensez qu'on doit faire des
propositions réalistes où on doit les
faire complètement utopique folle qu'est
ce qu'on va faire est-ce que est comme
ça au moins demain on sait qu'on va être
écouté aussi que ici monsieur le
président est monsieur michel va parler
va dire écoutez on a eu la conférence
europe et on a eu des propositions
extraordinaire et j'ai vraiment
impossible je vous réponds avec beaucoup
de franchise si je suis je suis je si je
suis égoïste je ne me serais pas si je
suis élu je vous dirais fait des
propositions réalistes va faciliter ma
vie sur le débat européen
mais comme je suis passionné très
convaincu par cette ambition rappelle
devons avoir collectivement fait des
propositions utopiste on a besoin d'un
idéal et je pense est certes on a besoin
on a besoin que notre génération elle
est la même capacité de rêve d'idéal
d'utopie qui a été celle de ceux il ya
plus de 70 ans qui après cette bière
trail se sont dit on va changer le
modèle on va renverser la table et on va
bâtir un espace de paix prospérité c'est
ça qui s'est passé quand j'en parle j'ai
des frissons parce que je me souviens de
nos grands parents de vos grands parents
de tous ceux qui ont été victimes c'est
à dire mondial sur le sol européen et
partout dans le monde et je pense qu'on
a besoin maintenant que ce même de ce
même déclic ce même élan donc du coup là
aujourd'hui ma conférence de l'europe à
paris qui va voir le
en fait on doit faire des propositions
utopiste allez on y va allez-y c'est le
rêve à lézignan et je croise on se donne
rendez-vous après le pont s'est repenti
où les pour ces européennes sera
peut-être plusieurs qui sont nécessaires
qui se pencheront sur les conclusions de
la conférence on peut se donner
rendez-vous et on verra tout journée je
suis garé à 12 tonnes rappelle être
ambitieux qui est je prends je prends au
mot alors là moi je le promets à six
nations c'est que tu sélections merci
beaucoup merci merci
alors que c'était très surpris je
pensais pas qu'il était aussi abordable
si sympa
annoncé en fait on suit une image trop à
trois rites et des positions pour
vraiment
direction la commission justifie de
traverser la route c'est juste en face
voilà c'est avec la commission c'est
encore autre chose première chose que je
fais je compte des femmes y en a 12
nous sommes est et la 14 team ah c'est
beau enfin moi où il ya autant d'hommes
que de femmes
un bel endroit pour montrer que la femme
là ça passe
ça y est cinéma
viacom qui donne un petit peu visités on
est là et on est entré dans une salle où
il y avait des journalistes tous les
midis je crois qu'ils ont un programme
ou débattent pendant une demi-heure bien
bonjour et bienvenue à notre réunion
2010 j'appelle sonia à me joindre sur le
podium pour une annonce sur l'année
européenne de la jeunesse et des porte
parole par domaine les points de vue des
jeunes partager lors de la conférence
sur l'avenir de l'europe façonneront
également les actions et les événements
organisés au cours de l'année en très
peu de temps il parle de beaucoup de
choses il faut avoir la réponse il ya
beaucoup de tel que
quelques petites précisions à propos de
la conférence climat la seconde au
kosovo votre réponse est notre second la
justice polonaise est ce que les
autorités polonaises ont déjà accepté la
présence de la délégation d'el aqsa est
ce que la commission pour évaluer de
signer un contrat avec fox la fiscalité
non mais ça passer du coq à l'âne je
n'ai pas reçu assure
en plus il ya tous les accents donc je
parle quand même un peu anglais ok mais
le truc c'est qu'il ya des accents on se
dit mais qu'est-ce qui nous
faut
retenir c'est le match n 6 ou tout ce
que vous avez trouvé ça intéressant
hyper intéressante et technique
sa part dite du montant fait
cette annonce à dépend complètement du
jour en fait hier par exemple le collège
à discuter des prix de l'énergie en fait
l'augmentation des prix d'énergie en
europe elle dépend du prix du gaz or
l'europe est dépendante à 90% en ce qui
concerne la consommation de gaz des
importations principalement de russie de
norvège est ce qu'on appelle les marchés
spot lng c'est à dire le gaz liquéfié
naturelles notamment le qatar un peu les
états unis et comme la définition des
prix dépend en partie du prix du gaz sa
quantité d'informations on est l'unique
institution au monde avec la maison
blanche tous les jours à répondre aux
questions des journalistes seul effort
de transparence en tout cas ravi de vous
rencontrer
de rien et on est toujours aux
dispositions si vous avez des questions
merci merci beaucoup au revoir
prochaine étape c'est le parlement et je
me rends compte que je n'ai pas voté
bonjour bonjour
alan
jara êtes bienvenu du bonjour au
parlement européen c'est la maison des
citoyens européens we do
marseille j'étais ce week end mais j'ai
dehors qu'est-ce que j'ai bien mangé et
surtout j'ai voté au parlement
européenne on est 1 sélection et
et donc en allant au parlement européen
je me suis dit bon on va rencontrer des
personnes pour qui on aurait pu voter ou
retrouver on va peut-être changer avec
eux donc là bas la première personne que
j'ai rencontrée c'est karima delli donc
une personne très gentille avec qui on a
pu parler et vous emmène voir quelque
chose ok au sein du parlement européen
comme vous pouvez découvrir chaque
parlementaire donc chaque député est
rangé selon son pays et nous avons dans
cet étage un casier c'est à dire une
petite entrée où on va récupérer
justement des documents qui viennent eux
pas forcément des citoyens européens
mais de l'ensemble des ces fameux lobby
les lobbys c'est quoi c'est à dire
parfois ces groupes de pression qui
essaie justement d'influencer la loi et
donc ils ont droit au sein du parlement
européen de déposer selon leurs députés
moi c'est là et balleure petit courrier
leur petit document pour nous informer
de leur position sur tel et tel projet
et ses lobbys viennent comme ça alors
c'est pas non plus un moulin preuve
alors on peut rentrer au parlement si on
est à créditer est ce que c'est vraiment
les puissants ceux qui prennent toutes
les décisions ou pas elle va il faut
justement avoir des députés qui
résistent parce que nous notre rôle de
député européen s'est pas de défendre
les intérêts privés des uns et des
autres c'est de faire la loi pour
l'intérêt général notamment les citoyens
européens alors il est vrai que
bruxelles est réputée comme étant une
capitale des plus gros lobbyistes est à
ce point il ya des accords entre
lobby et certains parlementaires ici
alors il faut savoir qu est ce qu on
appelle lobby on peut avoir des méthodes
de lobbies venant d'auch ong les ong
environnementales met la pression par
exemple pour avoir une ambition
climatique sur tel et tel projet de loi
qui va être impressionnante là ce sont
des ong il découvre que greenpeace c'est
un lobby donc aujourd'hui est ce que
tout le monde sait que c'est un lobby
greenpeace tandis qu'ana d'autres par
exemple on peut avoir des lobbyistes de
l'industrie automobile qui eux vont
essayer de pousser notamment pour les
normes soient moins contraignante
alors là vous allez admirer le dôme du
parlement européen
voilà on est allé sur le toit parce
qu'il y avait une belle vue justement
sur le toit de son bâtiment le parlement
européen et j'en ai profité justement
pour lui poser une question on a tous
autour de nos amis sont routiers ou
autre et je pense après font que j'ai
côtoyés fait un transpondeur français
est aujourd'hui bien il a du mal à
travailler parce qu'il se fait marcher
dessus par les transports ou européenne
et pays de l'est ou peut-être la main
d'oeuvre moins chère où il ya de moins
de contraintes et là un moment donné
c'est vrai que pour tous les pays
d'europe c'est pas c'est pas quelque
chose d'égal quoi c'est peut-être un peu
compliqué alors il est vrai que un des
grands poison de l'europe c'est la
question du dumping social de mettre en
concurrence les salariés les uns contre
les autres c'est la raison pour laquelle
pour une première fois enfin ce sujet on
l'a ouvert dans la commission transports
que je préside pour harmoniser les
conditions de travail notamment des
routiers et aujourd'hui on a une
directive travailleurs détachés qui va
améliorer les conditions de travail des
routiers par exemple des routes et qui
venaient de pays de l'est ce qui venait
par nombre en france qui le week-end
dormait dans des parkings dans leurs
camions etc tout ça aujourd'hui c'est
interdit mais moi je dors dans le camion
tout le monde dans tous les routiers
dans le camion les personnes qui dans
l'hôtel elle elle voulait parler je
pense c'est ce qu'ils aient toutes les
petites fourgonnettes qu'on voit là les
moins trois tomes 5 c'est interdit de
dormir dans ces camionnettes mais dans
les camions c'est qu'ils paient que des
couchettes tout le monde dort dame dans
son camion donc c'est moi quand je
l'entends vous dire ça c'est ça moi ça
montre qu'elle est qu elle connaît
quelques elle connaît pas le sujet quoi
on a une obligation par exemple que le
ce qu'on appelle notamment le cabotage
c'est-à-dire que les camions doivent
retourner dans leur pays d'origine
avant c'était pas obligatoire
aujourd'hui c'est obligatoire parce que
certains restaient dans le pays où il
faisait leur export de marchandises mais
en même temps de laisser le camion est
donc cessons et salariés qui tournait et
ça ce n'est plus possible grâce
notamment à la législation que nous
avons fait adopter au sein du parlement
européen où elle est mauvaise foi ou
ne maîtrise pas son sujet parce que le
cabotage qu'il a été
assouplie le cabotage par rapport à
avant il n'y a pas de cabotage quand la
pologne est rentré en europe dans
l'europe qu'ils ont eu raison d'y aller
on ouvre les vannes au cabotage donc
déjà le cabotage et l'a énormément
je crois qu'ils peuvent charger et
décharger trois fois en france avant
d'être au dessus de repartir mais qu'il
contrôle à
la négociation de ce texte ça nous a
pris trois ans oui c'est long mais
l'europe au fait c'est comme une
copropriété c'est tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord un moment on peut pas faire
les travaux vous voyez donc là sur ce
dossier on a bien avancé
bonjour bonjour thierry mariani sarazen
bellia je vais chanter merci parce qu'il
fait beau à bruxelles donc je pense que
vous nous avez apporté le soleil de
notre région exactement le but vise à
écouter on va aller dans l'hémicycle
l'hémicycle normalement les sessions
c'est à strasbourg
est d'accord ok c'est vraiment comme ça
fait du monde voilà je vous avais les
groupes qui sont répartis donc ça va de
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite mais
qui vous vous à troll c'est quoi en fait
en commun commissaires parce que si vous
ne mangez pas commissaire moi je suis à
la commission des affaires
internationales
donc moi je lui dit et comme vous êtes
commissaire est l'une dit je suis membre
de la commission des affaires étrangères
alors c'est la même chose regardez une
question très importante qui en débat en
ce moment les questions de défense
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire comme
politique européenne de défense ensemble
c'est ça l'objectif c'est trouver un
accord commun après c'est sûr qu'on sera
jamais d'accord sur plein de points mais
c'est trouver la meilleure solution pour
que ça arrange tout le monde les anciens
pays du bloc de l'est la seule chose qui
les intéresse l'otan pour la sécurité
l'europe pour les subventions c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont rentrés et qu'est ce que
vous préférez d'abord votre sécurité ou
les subventions dans priorités vous
pensez à votre sécurité et vous voyez
très bien que tous ces pays là un des
moments moi je on aurait pu faire une
europe forte je pense qu'on aurait pu la
faire à 6 10 15 mais à partir du moment
où elle a intégré ces pays là qui sont
intimement liées à la défense américaine
et qui pensent que l'otan mais leur seul
salut ne feront jamais rien qui puisse
concurrencer les états unis et l'europe
ne fera jamais rien c'est pour ça avec
toute la sympathie que j'ai pour vous je
pense que la conférence que vous faites
est très intéressante
mais
je pense que malheureusement je veux pas
vous décevoir ça débouchera sur rien
s'il ya eu une modification des traités
alors là je vous invite dans le meilleur
restaurant de bruxelles
ce mardi merci de votre merci merci
j'ai pas voté aux élections européennes
mais aujourd'hui cette expérience fait
que automatiquement je sais que ça va
avoir un impact hyper important j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses juste moi je
pense que tout ce qu'on apprend à
l'école belge là en quelques jours 11,7
et rapide commencer
pour
après bourse est direction paris
[Musique]
ça y est je la vente et le traducteur
sous-préfet mois
ça devait pas y avoir pour la première
fois dranak quand on arrive on voit la
tour eiffel et la caisse qui dit
beaucoup impressionné dire ils
obtiennent il peut pas dire ça c'est la
capitale c'est le moment
magnifique de la france
[Musique]
mais là
on va rentrer
multifonds enertrag
bien
mais m
[Musique]
on va pouvoir rouvrir officiellement
maintenant cette conférence nationale
sur l'avenir de l'europe
qui m'a impressionné en fait
effectivement au niveau des rencontres
des gens qu'on ne connaissait pas
pouvoir les changer je pense que c'était
début évidemment moi je me dis ben là
c'est le moment de parler qui a tous les
citoyens citoyennes françaises qui sont
là de la france et des dom-tom donc
c'est à ce moment là qu'il faut parler
bonjour à tous
c'est impressionnant de venir à paris un
message à faire passer est très très
important qu'on est parti à bruxelles on
rencontre richard michel si je vous dit
charles michel sait qui il est belge
pardon donc la commission exactement et
effectivement avec à l'aller on a eu la
chance c'est pas le président je
conditionne excusez moi te parle de la
commission c'est du conseil de l'europe
et c'est là où tout ça prend tout son
sens
conseil conseil européen ouais voilà
avec le conseil européen je vais y
arriver je vais y arriver parce qu'on a
vu plein de personnes mais s'il faire
important du conseil européen c'est le
président du panthéon
[Musique]
c'est compliqué la soirée alors et où
c'est moi ou c'est parce qu'il saurait
se laisser faire j'ai essayé de souffler
un petit peu derrière les deux trois
trucs mais moi mais moi je savais pas
tout mais elle s'est bien débrouillé est
ce que on doit être réaliste
est-ce que les propositions aspects
peuvent être utopique est ce que ça peut
être le rêve et c'est la question que
j'ai posée à charles michel et il a dit
oui complètement et bien c'est vraiment
il faut sortir de la zone un peu de
confort et dieu de la réalité et 10
rebonds a inventé des choses c'est
vraiment pousser les choses aujourd'hui
on a la chance de se réunir tous
ensemble on ait une diversité de ouf
commandiez de fou on peut dire tout ce
qu'on veut merci vos concitoyens
faut arrêter de dire non mais c'est bon
toute façon y'a rien qui va se passer
mais en fait si on fait rien n'y a rien
qui se passe dans la vie donc
aujourd'hui c'est se dire ok là c'est là
donc c'est know who never
[Musique]
le soir arrive au quai d'orsay avec des
carrés vip
monsieur magnifique vous êtes tous bois
si l'on se dit waouh quoi
imaginer
moi j'appelle ma mère je voulais appeler
mes soeurs et ma mère parce que je me
disais mais je suis quelque part où
c'est pas possible vous voulez partager
sinon je suis le quai d'orsay maman
regarde les lustres c'est vraiment ce
que tu aimes regarderai
kabous à la télé eh ben je suis dans
laquelle et tamar elle adore tout ce qui
est bling bling et tout ça et c'est
vraiment ça avec mes illustres et où
elle dit moi
[Musique]
soirée à toutes et à tous bardon de vous
interrompre dans un moment il ya l'air
déjà très convivial et très chaleureux
je suis clément bol de secrétaire d'état
aux affaires européennes très heureux de
vous recevoir ici ce soir au quai
d'orsay vous avez répondu parfois au
départ je crois un coup de fil un peu
étrange au début de l'été qui vous
disais est ce que voulait parler
d'europe en week-end et vous avez été
suffisamment fou pour lire oui merci à
tous
[Applaudissements]
et vous les 27 est temps que nous avons
aujourd'hui commente pour harmoniser un
peu tout ça pour justement parce que à
en vouloir une europe ça veut dire qu'on
aura à voir des des lois un peu communes
des vals de choses mais j'ai un peu mais
je pense que paradoxalement pour rester
ensemble je pense qu'il faut accepter de
différencier sur ce principe il ya des
moments on n'arrive pas à être plus
d'accord avant de sa discipline ou du
pôle tout vous concrètement l'état
fédéral vais vous dire les idées que je
pense que c'est souvent les idées des
plus concrètes sumann et guay ouvrez des
réalisations concrètes et des
solidarités de fait quand vous dites ils
font tous les jeunes ne relatent dans
les dix ans qui viennent s'est tous fait
six mois un an à l'étranger
ça paraît assez folle ça change tout a
concouru en même temps c'est vraiment ça
c'est des idées simples qui existe déjà
mais les élargir et à avoir une élite
qu'il puisse le faire mais que ce soit
accessible à tout le monde
et
c'est un très bon choix de répartir les
citoyens on se plaint toujours de pas
pour s'exprimer en france est bon là
c'est l'europe comme cinq ans présents
et le fait de pouvoir s'exprimer c'est
en avant ses succès et pays européens
qui maintenant ont essayé de le cacher
c'est qu'on montre l'exemple la france
émet notera d'abord parce qu'on peut
parler
[Musique]
j'ai appris plein de choses j'ai pu
m'exprimer je rencontre des gens super
de chaque région maintenant et le shaq
horizons ce sont des personnes
retraitées des jeunes des moins jeunes
des travailleurs n'importe quel talent
sociale dans ce
tract
c'est
une pub tout comme c'est comme la
conversion écologique écolo qui va
essayer
c'est pareil c'est histoire de dire le
bon roi demain de la vie à son peuple
mais on connaît déjà les réponses voilà
on sait très bien que c'est juste
histoire de se donner bonne conscience
et d'arrivée de pouvoir dire un discours
ben là je demandais la vie des gens on
va en tenir compte mais on va quand même
ça comme en a envie comment on fait tout
la prochaine étape c'est la restitution
ça va être présenté à la commission
européenne et bien sûr et du coup on
aurait rendez vous avec charles michel à
bruxelles pour en discuter pour voir
qu'est ce qui a été mis en place dont
moi j'attends ce rendez-vous puisqu'il
l'a dit de vive voix donc j'attends ça
et le restaurant bien sûr avec monsieur
mariani que vous choisirez l'excellent
cresson rendant donc c'est bien sûr
non
[Musique]